du baratin parce que depuis toujours on
polémique en france sur l'histoire
depuis deux siècles parce qu'on aime
l'histoire si molière et non mais je
d'ivoire était dit suffit qu'on prenne
position qu'on critique pour que l'on me
dit oui mais toi tu aimes pas l'histoire
de france ça me passionne ça m'énerve ça
mais il ya plein de gens qui écoutent
encore j'ai pas mal à supposer qu alexis
non mais je te prendre une chaîne de
télévision comme vous comme ces news cet
après midi durant l'hommage à william on
est il ya un gars qui a dit sur le
plateau il ya des gars comme cordiales
parler de moi qui déteste l'histoire de
france à ce que je critique n'a
forcément ce qu'ils ont dit ça ce que je
veux dire c'est que critiquer on
m'explique ce qu'ils disent quand même
le pied en prenant avec l' esclavage
soi-disant une méprise ray l'histoire de
france alors que c'est parce que j'aime
l'histoire de france et qu'il faut être
fier d'être français
on est le prix premier pays au monde à
avoir aboli l'esclavagé en compte qu'en
fait il le faisait même les états unis
d'amérique avait encore des esclaves
donc on devrait être fiers et dire nous
le grand pays en 1794 on a aboli
l'esclavagé entière de renaissance elle
est là elle est pas du côté on sait bien
au delà de l'esclavagé mais toi tu l'as
d'or tu as les tableaux sur canal+ on va
manger on va manger des des tacos 3
bien sûr c'est pas salé des biens des
charges et je vous ai ri les puissants
[Applaudissements]
il est raccordé
[Rires]
m